c'est le porte étendard de l'agriculture
technologique la start-up hortics et
nous sommes avec son fondateur et
dirigeant Olivier Ruchaud bonjour
bonjour Nicolas
[Musique]
alors vous avez rejoint le ski cube en
2018 vous faites partie de ces start-up
ancienne maintenant et puis d'ailleurs
vous allez quitter le ski cube très
prochainement puisque à la fin de la
semaine on commence à faire nos cartons
et on déménage à Promopole en
l'occurrence pas très loin d'ici alors
quel bilan vous faites justement de ces
de ces années passées ici au ski cube
alors un bilan qui est globalement très
positif parce que en partant d'une idée
où ça gère dans les dans le cerveau on
est tout seul à la situation à laquelle
on est arrivé aujourd'hui on a
aujourd'hui emploi quatre personnes à
temps complet en CDI et deux alternants
donc on est arrivé à une quelque chose
de concret commercialisé sur lesquels
les ventes d'écoles donc ma foi positif
et puis on le voit derrière vous cette
solution c'est scopique alors un mot
rapide sur ce qu'est ce que X en fait
scopix c'est une solution de traçabilité
agricole et la vocation qu'on s'est
donné c'est de mettre le numérique au
service des agriculteurs en apportant
quelque chose de très simple en en fait
au travers de ce scopic on répond à une
problématique double une problématique
réglementaire celle de la traçabilité et
puis une problématique de temps sur les
agriculteurs ont beaucoup d'activités et
l'enregistrement traçabilité ça
constitue une corvée pour eux et alors
du coup qu'est-ce que vous a apporté le
ski cube pour en arriver là alors
d'abord l'accompagnement de départ à
partir de passer de l'idée à un
prototype quelque chose de concret ça
passe par un certain nombre de comment
dire de challenges de discussion avec
des accompagnants de réfléchir à quelle
est la valeur qu'on apporte de réfléchir
à comment on arrive sur le marché tout
ça fait partie de l'accompagnement mais
en fait pour tout dire la partie la plus
importante pour moi dans la création
c'est celle de pas être tout seul c'est
celle de pouvoir partager avec des pères
c'est celui de pouvoir se confronter à
d'autres perceptions et c'est vraiment
là où on a un gain à venir ici
s'installer et moi je suis dans un
bureau depuis des années pour croiser du
monde et c'est pour ça aussi que vous
faites le choix d'aller à Promopole
c'est une autre pépinière d'entreprise
il y aura d'autres les gens avec vous
c'est ça c'est un petit peu le sens
c'est effectivement c'est un élément
pour moi important ce partage avec
d'autres comment dire d'autres créateurs
d'entreprises d'autres entrepreneurs
effectivement promopoles ils prennent
beaucoup alors vous quittez le ski que
vous allez à Promopole 2023 ça va être
quelle année pour Artix
à vrai dire ça va être la neige j'espère
du décollage commercial j'ai recruté un
responsable commercial et maintenant
quelques mois il est en train de
vraiment monter en puissance et
l'objectif c'est vraiment de faire 2023
concrètement une accélération
commerciale c'est-à-dire que là
aujourd'hui vous avez déjà plusieurs
partenaires au niveau France au niveau
régional comment j'ai des partenaires
dans le domaine coopératif agricole sur
les hauts de France l'est l'ouest
parisien et puis également un partenaire
avec la Banque Populaire sur le sud
parisien donc on est déjà on va dire on
couvre presque la moitié du territoire
objectif l'Europe
alors objectif l'Europe ça fait partie
des ça fait partie des projets
on se projette sur sur l'Europe
potentiellement au début de d'approche
en 2024 et puis si ça s'y prête si on
trouve un marché si on trouve des
partenaires pourquoi pas un
développement plus large en 2025 merci
beaucoup Olivier Ruchaud dirigeant
d'ortie c'est donc
ordres années puisqu'elle était incubée
ici depuis 2018 et qui a suivi un
programme à la fois d'incubation mais
aussi d'accélération